استخدام سيارات الاجره للتنقل يعتبر
رفاهيه للعديد من المقيمين والعاملين في
العاصمه البريطانيه لكن العديد من الاشخاص
يجدون انفسهم مضطرين لصرف جزء كبير من
رواتبهم على خدمات التاكسي اوبر بسبب
الالغاءات المتكرره لرحلات القطار او مترو
الانفاق سواء بسبب الاعطال او الاضرابات
او نقص اعداد الموظفين
انا مضطر لتعديل مواعيدي لانني لا اعيش في
لندن لذلك المجيء الى لندن اقوم بتعديل
مواعيد العمل مع الحرص على وجود عدد كاف
من القطارات في اليوم المحدد لقد قررت في
الصيف خلال الاضرابات الى البقاء في لندن
وهو ما يكلفنا اكثر لانني مضطره للسفر في
اوقات وايام مختلفه
رغم تفهم الاسباب وراء الاضرابات الا ان
البعض يعتبر ان الالغاءات المتكرره تزيد
من همومهم ومعدلات توترهم خصوصا في ظل
غلاء المعيشه الذي يشغل بالهم
انه امر غير مريح وافكر دائما في كل الناس
المعنيين بالاضرابات واعرف شخصيا اناسا
تاثر بها لكن في الوقت نفسه اتفهم لماذا
تحدث الاضرابات
لكن عددا كبيرا من الناس يفعلون ذلك وانا
متفاجئ في الواقع من عدد الناس الذين
ياتون الى لندن انه امر يبعث على سرور
وسجلت المملكه المتحده الغاء اكثر من 300
الف رحله قطار خلال العام اي بمعدل رحله
واحده بين كل 26 رحله او نحوي 860 رحله
يوميا وهو اعلى معدل سجل للالغاءات وضعف
عدد الرحلات الملغاه منذ عام
201576 من هذه الرحلات بسبب الاعطال
التقنيه التي تتحمل مسؤوليتها الشركات
الخاصه التي تدير القطارات وهو ما دفع حزب
العمال الى تقديم وعود باعاده اداره
القطارات الى الملكيه العامه عند انتهاء
عقود المشغلين
البريطانيون اول مقيمون هنا من ترد خدمات
النقل ومن الاضرابات التي تشم القطاع بين
الحين والاخر وتعب عاملوا قطارات ومترو
الانفاق من عجزهم مع دفع نفقات المعيشه
هنا وحتى يصل القائمون على المشاوره الى
حل الوسط بين النقابات وبين ارباب العمل
من المتوقع ان تشهد حياه الناس هنا المزيد
من الاضطرابات من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه